Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie. Marvel just released
way more deleted scenes from Spider-Man.
No Way Home with a bunch of new references
and big changes from the theatrical cut,
including a bunch of Iron Man Easter Eggs.
Even Ned Leeds hobgoblin Easter eggs.
So we'll break it all down.
There was so much stuff
that they tried in this movie,
so many deleted scenes
that if they'd included everything,
it would have been like a six hour movie,
which I totally would have sat through.
That would have been awesome.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We have Asoka episodes
coming up in a couple of weeks.
I'll do videos for all those
then. Loki Season two episodes.
Of course
I'll be doing videos for everything,
the first big deleted scene
like first big thing here is Willem Dafoe
as Green Goblin,
stealing a whole bunch of Iron Man armor
to create a new armor suit for himself
after he reveals
the Goblin persona is taken over
and Happy's apartment and kills Aunt May.
There are a couple versions
of deleted scenes of
what would have happened
next between this point in the movie.
Like when he has the big evil turn where
Aunt Mae dies in all three Spider-Man,
then fight him and the other Sinister
Six dance at the Statue of Liberty.
Like this whole section of the movie
there are a bunch of completely different
deleted scenes that all pretty much
take place during this part of the movie.
But after Willem Dafoe as Green
Goblin would have left him in the rubble.
He was going to fly his glider
to the damage control facility
and trade it for more advanced
Iron Man tech to upgrade his arsenal.
this was meant to be the same damage
control facility
where they took all the stark tech.
Edith Drones in the same place
where they had interrogated Spider-Man
and everyone else earlier in the movie.
also the same place where that daredevil
and happy Hogan scene took
place later in the movie.
during the first version of
this deleted scene, there was Green Goblin
stealing Iron Man's armor tech.
This looks like the Iron Man Mark six
that he created during Iron Man
two to be used with that upgraded element
based on the Infinity Stone technology,
Notice.
He also has one of the Edith drones.
That's how he got the drone,
because all the drones
were at that same damage control facility.
it looks like in this version of the scene
they had planned on having it
replaced his traditional Green Goblin
glider that he had brought with him
from Toby Maguire's universe
when he teleported from the MCU.
But the first spell
a lot of you will also recognize
this is also meant to be an Easter egg
for comic book. Norman Osborn.
During dark rain,
he winds up stealing Iron Man's technology
during dark rain
that happened right after Secret Invasion,
which we just saw to turn himself
into the Iron Patriot,
which they're kind of doing now
in Marvel, Phase five with some changes.
a lot of that original comic book.
Norman Osborn plot
they're giving to Thunderbolt,
Ross and Val, and he's becoming
the president. United States.
but in the original comic book version,
Norman Osborn took credit for getting rid
of all the bad skrulls and uses that wave
of popularity to take over shield
steal all of Iron Man's armor, technology
and creates the Dark Avengers
with a bunch of villains
replacing normal hero
versions of the characters in the MCU,
in the upcoming movies.
That's basically what's happening during
Captain America four in the Thunderbolts
movie with some more changes.
They're doing the Thunderbolts team
as a sort of replacement
for comic book Dark Avengers in
they're using some other plots to tie
in to Captain America
for like the Red Hulk plot.
They'd already done a more legit version
of Iron Patriot during Iron Man three
in having the Green Goblin repaint
his armor, two Iron Patriot, accurate
armor and Spider-Man No Way Home wouldn't
really have made sense in this context.
there was another version
of the same scene where he does everything
the same way, but he winds up
repainting the Iron Man armor
to a more traditional Green Goblin
purple color.
Otherwise same basic theme
then there was another version
of the same basic deleted scene where
instead of stealing Iron Man's old armor,
he still has dark elf armor
The damage control had been storing
at the same facility left over from Thor,
the Dark World.
Remember during that movie,
there were a bunch of dark elves
that made it to Earth
in a bunch of their stuff was left over.
Damage control went up cleaning it up.
It turns out they just had a bunch of it
leftover from that.
they wanted to use the dark elf helmet
to make him a more comic book,
accurate looking version of Green Goblin.
Like they said that that was a big thing
during the movie.
Like we wanted to push him
in a more comic book looking direction,
and this was intended to do that.
there was another version, this scene
where he refashioned
all that armor
like the Iron Man tech, the dark elf
take the stuff the damage control
had into something that's more akin
to the design language
that you saw in the Tobey Maguire movies,
the next big scene was a hobgoblin
reference scene.
Everyone had all these questions
about them doing Natalie's hobgoblin.
At some point there were even some posts
from the actor Jacob Batalon egging people
on, teasing people about the Hobgoblin.
But it turned out
he was just messing with people.
it looks like during the movie
they actually planned on doing
more legit references to comic book
Ned Leeds Hobgoblin.
This scene would have happened
at the Statue of Liberty Battle.
Obviously during that Ned Leeds
would have jumped on to Green Goblin
Glider at some point
is sort of throwing his goblin bombs
at the other Sinister six villains
they didn't go into too much detail
about what was happening here.
But my assumption is this would have been
after Tobey Maguire, Andrew Garfield,
Tom Holland, Spider-Man, not Green Goblin
off the glider, But before Tom Holland.
Spider-Man
would have fought him on the ground,
using the glider to almost kill him.
like at some point,
Ned Leeds winds up jumping on the glider
to stop himself from falling.
And there are a bunch of goblin bombs
left over that
he winds up
throwing at the other villains.
most people remember Ned Leeds
as the original Hobgoblin because
he was the first person in the comics
to be revealed as a hobgoblin.
But they actually retcon this
A little bit later in May, Ned Leeds
the second version of the Hobgoblin.
It's that he'd been brainwashed by the
first version to serve as his replacement.
Maybe someday they'll do
some Easter eggs for this.
But it sounds like they don't plan on
doing a whole lot of that,
especially in Spider-Man four,
because they have all this plot
with Daredevil
and what's happening
with the symbiote saga.
I do think that Ned Leeds will be back
in this upcoming Tom Holland's
Spider-Man trilogy, like Spider-Man four
or five or six at some point.
then there was a more funny deleted
scene of Spider-Man going to confront
Jonah Jameson
after Batman's death in his home studio.
Notice he's not wearing his mask here,
and he's still wearing the older version
of the costume
there's so much stuff
going on in this scene,
like so many different jokes
all blending together.
he's doing the broadcast
without any pants on
because this is from his studio
and you only see him from the waist up.
A lot of YouTubers
actually filmed their videos this way.
They're on camera.
I don't think I've ever actually filmed
a YouTube video.
Only wearing my underwear.
Like this seems kind of crazy.
But you'd be surprised.
The number of people who do this
or the number of people who wear like,
really nice clothes
for the top half of their body
and they just wear shorts in the bottom
half.
there was a lot of this going on
during the pandemic, too, where you saw
like news broadcasters,
like official news,
really important people
filming videos like this
because everybody was working
from their homes.
The other joke here is that Jonah Jameson
looks like a total hoarder.
Like his room here is crazy
and he's a crazy cat person.
Like the dude version of a crazy cat lady.
There are at least
seven different cats that I can see around
frame in the background here.
pause the video and let me know
if you can spot any other cats
that are hiding in the background here.
I wouldn't be surprised.
They're even more during the final battle,
there was another scene of MJ
wearing the cloak of levitation,
and it would have replaced
the scene of Ned Leeds
wearing the cloak of levitation.
But the same basic idea, like same basic
thing happening in the scene.
He used the cloak of levitation
to slow his
or the cloak helped him to slow his fall.
It would have done the same thing for MJ
in this other deleted scene.
the next new scene is like
an extended scene of all three Spider-Man
on the Statue of Liberty
before the actual battle starts.
they discuss
how lucky they think all the Sinister
Six villains are going to be
now that they're going
to get a second chance in their lives
because they're curing them.
Peter three Andrew Garfield's character
says that he's loving this instance.
They should do it again
We should do this again.
You got it.
just setting out
the idea that they will return again
during Avengers six Secret
Wars, possibly
in some other future project besides that.
because when he says, Let's do this again,
he says, next
time, let's do it
without all the potential for us dying.
And and then Andrew Garfield, Spider-Man
talks to Tobey Maguire, Spider-Man saying,
I'll grab your number.
After talking about how they'll team up
on their own separately from this,
hopefully they'll pay that off sometime
soon, too.
Then they go into a slightly different
joke about the organic web shooters,
the Tobey Maguire has.
they asked if when he used the organic web
shooters.
It's a clean release,
like if it leaves a bunch of mess on him.
does he do it with his mind?
Does he just think Web
and the Web comes out
and then Tobey Maguire
Spider-Man says that he can't explain it.
It's sort of like riding a bike
in Andrew Garfield.
Spider-Man says, I want to see the holes.
talking about the holes in his wrists
where the webbing actually comes out.
then probably one of the other
biggest new scenes is the completely
alternate post-credits scene.
so this post-credits scene is Betty Brandt
on her TV show at the school reminiscing
about graduating high school like it's
at the very end of events in the movie,
She says it seems like only yesterday
that we were starting
an adventure called High School.
And what an adventure it's been.
during her broadcast,
they show another cringe
kind of funny montage
of the events of Spider-Man
homecoming, Spider-Man far from home,
some from the Washington Monument,
some from their adventures in Europe.
With Mysterio, so like,
they go on all these crazy adventures,
all the same stuff happened to them,
But it's as if the spell has erased
Peter Parker from all these events.
Remember,
the spell didn't erase Spider-Man.
So like, Spider-Man would still appear
in pictures if they took pictures of him.
But if it's Peter's actual face,
that's what's disappeared.
And that's what they've forgotten about.
Which is why all the Avengers characters,
for instance, remember Spider-Man
fighting with them during Avengers
Infinity War.
In Avengers Endgame.
The Like during Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness,
they treat it like they don't know
that Peter Parker is Spider-Man.
They just know that there is a Spider-Man
who has worked with them in the past.
Betty Brant continues her broadcast
talking about the events of the Blip
Avengers Infinity War.
ending the broadcast,
talking about how they'll cherish
all their memories,
showing pictures of them.
Also with Peter Parker erased from
all the photographs because of the spell
she ends the broadcast signing off saying,
Happy graduation, Go Tigers,
which is also a bit of a reference
to the classic Mary Jane phrase,
Go get em, tiger.
but really, this post-credits scene
is just meant to hammer home
the idea of how exact the spell erases
memory of him,
which is why he has to get the GED.
Because nobody
remembers his school records,
because they were taken his records
for Peter Parker himself.
the other big news is from Kevin Feige.
And he revealed that the plot of Daredevil
Born Again, will figure heavily
into the events of Spider-Man four
cannot wait to
see Daredevil and Spider-Man team
up to fight Kingpin
and for King to try and squish him
some Spider-Man
They're going to be filming the series
all this year, all the way to December.
So we're going to get a bunch more scenes,
but more of them
talking about new characters
and connecting
with the upcoming Marvel movies.
Of course I will do videos for everything
and I will do videos
for all the episodes.
When they start releasing them,
there will be eight
episodes total in season one,
but they are going to break the season.
I believe in a two halves. It
there'll be two.
Cause if you watch anime, they do that
all the time.
like season one, Part
one in season one, Part two.
but Vincent D'Onofrio recently explained
that they are developing season two,
so there will be multiple seasons
of the show
in addition to these 18 episodes
that they're currently filming.
There's a whole bunch of stuff coming up.
More Ahsoka trailers, more Loki Season two
trailers,
of course, will do videos for everything.
Make sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that
and click here for that.
Captain Britain
in Excalibur Teaser from Secret Invasion
and click here
for all my Comic-Con trailer videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!